- If you are not happy
right now you have to
break your patterns and
you have to look at life
from a different perspective.
You have to find a different
angle to look at it from
because this shit goes
fast even though it's long.
- Welcome to the Philippines, sir.
- Thank you, my friend, great to see ya.
So what's the story, you
were born in San Fran?
- I was born in San
Francisco, went to school
and I wanted to play, I mean that's every
Bay area kid's dream is to be a basketball
star in the NBA, that was my goal.
- You were tall, right?
- Yeah I'm this tall Filipino kid
that's gonna make it in the NBA.
Now I just realized I
wasn't good enough so
I was like maybe PBA.
- When?
- When I was in college.
- Okay.
- I couldn't even get into college,
it was like a community
college in San Francisco
and I couldn't get in basketball.
So I was like yeah I think
I'll just go to the Philippines
and try to make it in
Philippine basketball.
- And?
- I didn't make it!
I'm like damn!
Alright, it's time to give up that
dream and move onto something else.
So yeah, I got into acting,
I started auditioning.
It's a different
- Style
- Yeah, different companies or products
and yeah I didn't land
any commercials for like
six months I was going to like
- Literally I know exactly
why you're successful
because all you had was you
know, adversity coming up.
- I mean I just kept on getting shut down.
- Did you like it or do you hate it?
- I hated it.
- Yeah
- I don't like rejection,
dude, but I mean you gotta
- Did you respect it or were
you like this is bullshit
like people don't see it?
- I mean, oh what did you say?
- Did you respect it, you
were like okay I gotta
keep working my craft
or you were like this
is some bullshit, that
casting director is an idiot.
- The first one I was like yeah I gotta
keep on working at it.
- Okay, that's good.
- I mean it's good that I kinda had my
mom pushing me, she was like yeah just do
whatever you wanna do, there's gonna be
a lot of failures along the way but yeah.
Just keep on failing and
you'll make it eventually.
- And then what happened?
- And then finally I
landed like this big role
this like really small role on TV.
So there's only two or
three networks here.
- Yeah.
- So I got in a station and
they're like yeah hop on
you'll play a role and I
don't know I guess like
people just started
catching up and they started
seeing me and that's how
basically it started.
They're like yeah, okay his name's Xian
we'll start getting him for projects.
And that's how it started.
Started doing movies and stuff.
- That's amazing.
- Kinda worked my way up from there.
- What was the biggest, was
there a break or was there a
single thing or was it
just all step and step?
- There was this one
movie that they tried,
it was me and my onscreen
partner, her name is Kim,
so we did a romantic comedy
movie and it was like
number one back in 2013, and
it made like 300 million.
So we were like ah okay
cool, let's make another one.
So yeah, that's how it started.
That's like the big break
right there, movies.
- And so what's been going
on the last couple of years?
- The last couple of years I'm like,
dude I've been watching your videos man,
that shit's fired me so much.
- Thank you, man.
- No, really, like,
I don't know, I've been
pretty confused with
what I wanna do like, of
course I love what I'm
doing, I love acting, I
love doing all these things.
But there's like a part of
me that just wants to grow.
Like when you're saying in
your videos that the internet
platforms that you want to
just keep on creating, right?
- You can be global.
- Yeah, so I wanna do that,
but it's just really hard, man.
It's really hard.
- The good news is, so was getting to
the point where you got.
Like all that rejection, the best part is,
when I hear you go through your narrative,
I'm like okay good, that's
why I asked a couple
of nuanced questions on
like how'd you deal with
the rejections, like how much
do you like the rejection
and the toughest part
is when you're coming
from a low spot, you know
climbing or rejection
is a little bit different
coming from a luxurious spot
like success that you come from and
putting in patience again kinda sucks.
And by the way, I did it, I won in the
wine business and I started all over.
I won in kind of like
the online content thing,
then I started all over.
I transition from wine
content to business content.
And then even took another
step 18 months ago and was like
kinda of went pocketed and
Vayner Media, same thing.
Small, now it's getting big and honestly,
I can already sense four,
five, six years from now
when it's a billion
dollar company I'm gonna
be like alright I gotta go start from
to me it's you either love
the process or you don't.
If you want something
big, if you wanna grow,
I mean you've already pulled
off something that most people
never pull off, if you wanna
pull off something bigger
- Is that normal?
That's the question in my head right now.
- There is no normal, there's you, right?
Normalizing from other
people's experiences
aren't gonna bring you any value.
There's no normal, there's you.
- Yeah, that's true, that's true.
- Right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And there can't be normal.
Was it normal 20 years ago
to have two men filming this?
- I know, exactly, right?
- That's super not
fucking normal, you know?
- It's crazy!
- Vans are gonna have to get bigger,
we're running out of seats around here.
I think that the biggest thing
you need to think about is
don't quantity based on
other people's feelings
like are other people going through this.
All human behaviors are
somewhat at some level
to your question normalized.
There's fear, there's
anxieties, there's excitement,
there's confidence, there's insecurities,
there's a million different things.
I think the thing that's
interesting about you
is you're clearly driven,
you know first you
wanted to be in the NBA,
then you wanted to be
in the PBA, then you wanted to act.
I think the thing you need to understand
is that you've got a gear of
motivation that makes you do.
The first two things in
sports didn't work out.
The thing that worked out in
acting did work out, whatever.
The definition of what you're
trying to figure out right now
it may or may not work,
what I'm excited about
is the fact that you've got a gear
that makes you want to do.
- Yeah, exactly.
I mean I'm falling into that trap, though.
I saw your video which was
really helpful a couple of days
ago where you're like stop
comparing yourself to others.
- Who are you comparing yourself to?
Like the Rock?
No I mean that!
- I mean like you guys.
- Or like the big vloggers?
- The big vloggers and
they're like yeah oh my god.
- But look at me, right, I'm not growing
all that aggressively on YouTube.
My views per episode are
down probably year over year.
I'm just not worried
about it because I know
why I'm doing it, why I wanna do it.
And I think one of the biggest problems
right now, especially for
people under 30 who wanna
be influencers or entrepreneurs
which is almost everybody,
there's a lot of vanity
metrics that they're
trying to achieve to that mean nothing.
I raised 50 million dollars, so, you might
go out of business, I've
got a million subscribers,
so, I've got 10 million subscribers, so.
I think right now we
live in a world that has
so much data that people are
living towards the numbers.
How many likes, how many
followers, how much capital
I've raised, it becomes a numbers rat race
and it usually leads to bad behavior.
Because when you're chasing
a number that people
can see, you often take shortcuts.
- Yeah, I think that's the problem.
I'm too worried.
- Like Logan Paul has
nothing to do with you.
- Yeah, that's true.
- It just doesn't, Logan's
gonna do Logan, you're gonna do
you, I'm gonna do me
and Rex is gonna do her.
It's great to be inspired by,
it's great to be inspired by.
It's great to use something
as like a north star
for ambition, but that
needs to be manifested
in a positive way, not a negative way.
- That's true.
- 'Cause what you're talking
about is actually envy.
When you're looking at
what somebody else has
you're talking about
envy, envy's bullshit.
- Yeah, that's true.
- I know I'm at my weakest when I
root for the New York Jets.
I envy teams that win
a lot of Super Bowls.
And I know what that feeling is.
That's a weak feeling,
I'm weak as a sports fan.
But as a human I'm the
reverse and that's why I
fully understand and the scary part is
most people are weak as humans.
They envy, and I'm like
get the fuck out of that.
Like I get pumped when I,
I'll give you a good example.
This kid Dunk that
worked for me for a year,
when I met him he had this
basketball account Dunk,
I don't know if you follow him
because you like basketball,
he had like two million
followers, I wasn't jealous of him
or being like this kid, I was inspired.
I was like good for you fucker,
you fucking are like
doing what I believe in.
And no question that was like a match of,
not that I wanted to compete with him
because he's like a
child of mine let alone
little brother, he's 19 or whatever,
but you know it's great to be inspired by
but being envious of and
it's a very very fine
line but I understand,
but it usually speaks
with being happy inside.
And I think the bigger thing
you need to think about
is do you love your process?
Like are you enjoying, is this fun?
I'm sure he's a lovely dude, is this fun
that you're filming this?
Or are you doing this because you think
it's gonna get you to the
next level of success?
And I think that that's an
important thing to understand.
For me, both, but if
I didn't love it, then
fuckin' there's a lot of things
I know I should be doing.
I should be answering
unlimited questions on Quora.
I just don't want to, so I'm not.
I wanna hire a writer to get that done
'cause it's a good idea, that's a little
fun fact for everybody out there.
You know, I should be
commenting more right
now with threaded comments on Instagram.
So I show up at the top
because I'm verified,
and get tons of audience.
- Oh is that how it works if you reply.
- I'm a big believer that if you're
fortunate enough to be verified right now
on Instagram you should be replying on
other verified accounts at scale.
But, not spammy, not just like yo
or a peach emoji if
somebody's got a cute butt.
But you should be replying
with something meaningful
because when people see
it, it's kinda like this,
I tweeted about last
night in Singapore about
if you do the follow
unfollow thing you're lame,
not because it may not work or work,
it's 'cause the intent is
not good, you follow somebody
hoping they follow you back and then you
unfollow them, it's posturing,
it's got the wrong intent.
But if you go and leave
comments on everybody
and you actually follow people
and become part of their
communities, like intent matters.
And so anyway, there's
a ton of things I know
I should be doing, but I don't do them
because they're not necessarily
the thing I love to do.
And I think only when you love it is
when it really gets cracking.
I didn't make a lot of
content, do a podcast,
all this other stuff, 'cause
what I was loving right then
was super head down
Vayner for three years.
Vayner got big enough and I got better.
I got better and I figured out a system.
I'm still living my business life,
D Rush is filming it,
which is why I wasn't
a vlogger the way that everybody else
grew up which is this, right?
Like this was KC this
was Logan, this was you
know everybody else, I
didn't roll that out.
Because if I was doing
that, I wouldn't have
been able to do my life.
That's how I came up with this.
- Yeah.
- Got it?
- Yep.
- This was unique and maybe
even douchey and awkward
and definitely socially not
acceptable three years ago.
- Do you have your camera
guy follow you like
- Everywhere.
This was super socially
awkward three years ago and now
- And now it's kind of accepted.
Like people are like oh
okay, cool, he's vlogging.
- And that's that.
So I think what you need
to think about is a very
big reason acting probably worked out was
you both thought it
could bring you something
you were looking for
from a level of attention
and success and fame and dollars,
but you also like it,
because otherwise if you
didn't like it, you
would've quit after the
third no at auditions.
- I know right
- When you do something
for money, you quit.
When you do it because you
love it, you do it forever.
- You keep going right?
- A hundred percent.
People quit all the time 'cause
they do it for the money.
Crypto currency, real
estate, tech investing,
it's all because whatever's a hot market.
All those markets go up and down,
they go up and down from
the reasons they create
big bubbles is because an enormous amount
of people are in it for the money.
- Just for the investment.
- For the money, not for the investment,
for I want money to do
something with that money.
I think the bigger question is well what
do you want that money for.
- I have one question,
in terms of structure,
am I supposed to have my own structure
- What does that mean?
- Am I supposed to be
- Are you talking about agents, production
companies, all that?
- No, I mean, in terms of how I put out my
videos am I supposed
to have like a schedule
am I supposed to have like
- I see, look I think you have to respect
an audience, I do think a scheduled time
is something people enjoy-ish.
But I think you can win either way.
I mean are you asking noon everyday or
are you asking do it everyday?
- Yeah, kinda like that.
Am I supposed to be
- You're supposed to do nothing.
- Okay
- So like, you've gotta understand
an audience is gonna react a certain way,
but let me say this, if you tell me,
when I hear that question I don't want
him to have a schedule because the fact
that you're even asking it means
it's a stress point for you
- It is, like what am I gonna do!
- So to me if you think, if I said to you
if somebody who you admired advice and
I said to you you have to do it five
days a week at noon, it's probably not
gonna succeed 'cause the pressure or the
anxiety of having to do that when
it doesn't come natural
or interesting to you
breaks it down.
If I said to you, create and put out when
you have things that you're
inspired by or you're feeling
it, well then you've got something.
- That's right.
Perfect, perfect.
- It's all an inside game.
I think the bigger question
is like what are you up to?
Like why are are you doing it, what's up?
- I gotta ask myself that.
I never really ask myself that.
- You have to ask that
because is it blocking
an insecurity, is it to get the girl,
is it 'cause you're trying to
mask as much as you can 'cause
you actually don't like
working and you wanna live.
The reason so many people
fail in life and business,
is their model is let
me get the money so that
I can enjoy and relax, they think of it
as like hoarding it and then eating it
all over time, retirement
and all that stuff.
It's such a bad way to think.
Because then you're feeling the pressure
of amassing so you can enjoy.
You need to be enjoying the amassing
so much that you never
get to the enjoying part.
Like I will never retire.
- That's good.
- 'Cause it's not as fun as working.
Like it's not as fun, it's not as fun for
me to lay on the beach
and play golf all day
and lay on a yacht in the middle of
the Mediterranean for
100 days in the summer
and go to vineyards and go
to concerts and see friends.
That's not as fun as fucking
15 hours of meetings all day.
That is what people have to figure out.
Whether that's singing or being a mother
or teaching a classroom, what
is more fun than the cliche
things that everybody
puts in their Instagram?
I don't wanna lay in a swan in a pool.
I don't want to, I don't want
to go to Ibiza for four days.
I do not want to, I don't.
I want to sit there and smile.
I'm literally the reverse human.
People go in their
feeds and they have FOMO
'cause everybody's in Ibiza and swans,
I'm smiling 'cause I'm
like, you're in Ibiza.
Do you understand, 'cause
if you're in Ibiza,
and I'm putting in work,
my machine's getting big.
And like to me the game matters.
And by the way, somebody may be looking
and being like Gary
looks like shit, four AM,
six flights in Asia and
I'm sitting here in Ibiza
and for her or him that's
winning, and that's great.
Figure out what your fucking winning is.
My winning is different
than a lot people's.
I don't get envy, I get
excited, I get competitive.
I enjoy it, I enjoy my
thing, what's your thing
that makes you the happiest.
- And just focus there.
- Only there.
You gotta ask why, what are you chasing.
- Maybe what's happening to me now
is I'm looking at all these accounts
- A hundred percent.
- Should I be doing this, I'm like that.
- What you're realizing in
culture and you know is that
the attention is going
away from the movie and the
television and going into the
phone and these platforms.
- That's true.
- So you can feel that you want something
and now it's going away.
- Yes, exactly, there you go.
- Brother I know what the score is,
I know what the score is.
But I think you need to not
look at that as a negative,
you need to look at that as a positive
because if you were an
actor from 25 years ago,
you would've just become complacent.
You're lucky that the game's forcing you
to have to be sharp again.
Either you look at it as
a positive or a negative.
People would say oh this is a negative,
you're losing your throne.
I'm saying no, no, no, this is awesome.
You get to keep playing, that's
somebody who loves the game.
- Gotta keep playing.
- I think I sandbag myself from success.
I could have way more
success, but I'm trying to,
I'm foreplaying my life.
- Okay.
- While everybody's playing Fortnite I'm
foreplaying my life and my career.
- What do you mean by that?
- I mean I'm slow rolling it.
Like I'm foreplaying it.
Like I'm holding off fore
more enjoyment later.
- Oh, okay.
- You know, but I
honestly, genuinely believe
that's what I'm doing with my career.
Like, listen, D Rock will tell you I came
off of vacation and said
you know what and said
I'm holding off too much,
let me get a little more
offensive and I said
I'm gonna fix Instagram,
I'm gonna fix my podcast, and
I'm gonna get into hip hop.
Well, 20 months later,
I'm doing just okay.
So I can turn it on and off
which is cool and that's
talent and that feels nice, but it speaks
to me liking it I think you need to
find something you love.
- You're also doing sports now, right?
- Yes, AJ and I, my brother, started
a sports representation
business, Vayner Sports,
repping NFL athletes, Jerry McGuire stuff.
So it's super fun.
We'll get into the NBA, too.
Any sports, those are kind
of places we're looking at.
So I'm excited about that.
- That's crazy.
- So you came here when you were how old?
- Like 18, 19.
- And now you're how old?
- I'm 29, turned 29 two days ago.
- You look good, man.
Two days ago, wait a minute, Liz.
You share the same birthday as my sister.
- [Liz] 13th?
- 12th cool, happy birthday, cancerions.
We're loving people.
- [Liz] We're hard on the
outside but super sensitive
- Very sensitive, we're very sensitive.
Wait, you're speaking here
right, in Hall of Asia?
- I have no fucking idea, Steve?
- [Steve] Convention, guys.
- Convention Center.
- [Liz] Celine's coming in
two days, you and Celine.
- This is like one of
my dreams, to be like an
inspirational speaker like
what you're doing right now.
It's so crazy.
- You like the live stage?
- Yes, and at the same
time, I wanna be able to,
'cause like right now I have
like most of my followings
are like old people and kids.
Old moms, like 40s
- [Liz] What's old moms?
- 40s and above!
Kinda like that, that's
kind of my demographic
- [Liz] I'm almost one
of your fans, I guess.
- So you have 40 year old moms and
- Little kids
- Because of the movies you've been doing?
Yeah, all the love stories.
So maybe last year I was like man I
wanna be like an inspirational speaker
you know like 'cause
all the kids sometimes
when I do meet and greets
they're like what should
I do blah blah blah like
they're asking me for advice, I'm
like man, one of these days I should be,
I wanna talk about like what you're doing.
But yeah I wanna be like that.
I wanna be able to give out advice.
- I generally think anybody can do it.
What I mean by that is
you can start tomorrow.
The biggest problem is,
the way people think
of inspiration speakers
now, unfortunately people
are putting up facades.
To me, the definition of somebody whose an
inspirational communicator is the person
who speaks the most truth.
You can do it tomorrow,
you're famous in this country.
If you go talk about your
insecurities, your strengths
and your weaknesses,
you'll be off to the races.
People don't even hear me
talking about my weaknesses.
I do it all the time, I suck
at school, I suck at this,
I can't do logistics, they
don't think it matters
'cause I've achieved success.
But they're things that
other people dwell on.
- The fear I'm getting at is I don't wanna
seem like I'm putting off like he's just
trying to be this or
- I agree, that's why
I'm giving you the advice
of don't try to be this, just go talk.
Be like, here's my story,
and then what starts
happening is you learn over time like
it took me awhile to
talk about the fact that
I don't own any of Wine Library.
That was something I kept inside.
But as I got to tell that that opened
up doors for other people.
I thought it kind of potentially looked
bad on my dad, and then I kind of looked
at it differently I'm like wait a minute,
that's what immigrant families do.
Then I opened up, now when I tell kids
to be patient, now they're
like wait a minute,
he's really started with nothing at 34.
I started YouTube, I started
business YouTube at 34
the wine I was 31, but
that business was my dad's.
Like I wasn't getting the money.
So, you know I think that,
yeah man it's about patience.
Like 29, literally 29
year old me, 13 years ago,
it was just a fundamentally
different person.
It was still me, right
I put out a video the
other day from 2008, and
everyone's like Jesus
it's basically the same
shit which is amazing.
But, there's so much
experience, there's so much
more perspective, different understanding.
And speaking has allowed me to get to it.
There's nothing more honest
than you and an audience,
especially when it's just you.
- Yeah, oh yeah.
- You know, I'm not in Broadway
plays, this is just me.
One man show, straight from the dome.
You know I don't have PowerPoints
or other things to hide
behind, like I genuinely
don't know what the
fuck I'm gonna say when I go on stage.
- Oh, nice.
- It goes in patterns,
I'll get into a pattern.
I'll get into a subject
matter, like this whole
trip is about parenting all of a sudden,
you know like, tell your truth, man.
- Yeah, that's what I'm gonna do.
- And honestly, your weakness
is predicated on your secrets
and your strengths are
predicated on your truths.
It's very real.
- It's been a blast.
It's been a blast hanging out with you
for like 20 minutes, man.
- For sure, man.
I really, you know what I like how you're
reacting to my commentary,
like you're gonna win, dude.
I poked and you didn't run away.
You said yeah, yeah, yeah.
So listen to me, I mean this
very, very, very seriously.
Own your truths, expose
your secrets, you'll
become a hundred percent unstoppable.
- I should do that, thanks.
Million dollar advice right there.
- Take care, brother.
- Thank you, Gary.
- We just finished up the
meeting, obviously took
a shower and changed a little bit on this
whirlwind Asian tour.
I think the interesting thing is literally
as I'm trying to put a bumper here,
is it a bumper, a tail
end, I don't fucking know,
nonetheless, there's a
debate right now going on
on Twitter of like, how
many years do you have
to work until the hard
work until the thing.
This guy's like Gary V you said you hustle
your face off for ten
years he's like I only
had to do it for two years I couldn't
imagine doing it for ten,
and I'm laughing at him.
And another guy jumps in
and goes, well Gary said it
best, eat shit for blank year and eat
caviar for the rest of your life.
And one of the things I'm realizing,
especially after the talk we just had,
is for me the shit is the caviar.
Like I love the fucking
process, I love building.
You just have to be self aware.
If for you life is
spending 30, 40, 50 years
on a beach with mansions
and playing tennis
all day and golf then that's amazing
and then I assume if
that's your great happiness
then you are gonna try to make
as much wealth as possible
as quickly as possible because you think
or you know that that's
what makes you happy.
I'm just really, really
interested in starting
to get this conversation into
a happiness conversation.
Like I just think a lot
of people are trying to
achieve success and use
fame or money as makeup
for a situation that they're
just not happy about.
Like you have to figure
out how to make your
day in and day out happy.
Otherwise you're gonna
be impatient and try to
be out of it as quickly as
possible to buy those things.
Or you're gonna regret
it later in life, right?
I think people that are
workaholics that regret
missing their family
is it didn't make them
as happy as they thought,
they didn't take advantage
of the family time, this is
just a big happiness game.
One big fucking happiness game.
And that young man has
achieved a lot at 29
and I'm just asking him why, like
'cause he has under a million
followers in Instagram
and he wants to have two million to what?
To keep up with the Jones's?
The Jones's have been brought
up a bunch on this trip
to me in my head an
conversations on and off screen.
And like I just want
to find these Jones's,
I want to find these
Jones's and kill them.
'Cause the fucking Jones's
are fucking you guys up.
And I don't know who
these fucking Jones's are,
but they're bad fucking people.
The Jones's are bad, bad people.
And they're ruining most of your lives.
And I just don't give a
fuck about the Jones's.
I don't know who the Jones's are and they
definitely don't have any impact on
my fucking life and so I figure out what
makes me happy and so
like that's what I do
and you need to figure out what that is
and I just don't
understand how people think
wealth is the gateway to
happiness, I just don't.
Or the gateway to happiness
is to love your process.
Whatever that may be, whether
that creates wealth or doesn't
if that creates legacy and art or doesn't,
that creates impact on
the world or it doesn't.
You've gotta try and figure
that out at all costs.
And if you're not happy right now,
you need to do something different.
If you are not happy right now you have
to break your patterns and you have to
look at life from a different perspective.
You have to find a different
angle to look at it from.
Because this shit goes
fast even though it's long.
(hip hop)